good morning it gets to this a bit
Connie was fun so fun in fact that it
took hardly any video except for this
anyway it was basically like that level
of sensory input for 72 straight hours
but before VidCon I was on a television
program called The Colbert Report which
meant makeup so I'm completely really
super into getting my makeup done you
have I told you this yeah no Jon
Bernthal won it and yeah I think I had
my makeup done on the whole the whole
time out on the movie to her okay like
first thing in the morning and they
touch it up all day long right I just
looked so good I felt so good on myself
I'm not even kidding
so what Bridget does my makeup Hank a
few makeup thoughts I confess that in
high school I was one of those guys who
was like you don't need to wear makeup
you're beautiful just the way you are
meanwhile of course I was covering my
body and carefully selected clothes
every morning showing that on some level
I did understand that humans generally
don't present themselves in public just
the way they are now obviously TV makeup
is different from everyday makeup but
here's what I like about makeup one it
feels good it feels good to touch your
face gently and kindly - it's like
really beautiful Armour because it makes
me feel more confident and somehow kind
of protected as I go through my day it's
sort of like wearing my favorite outfit
except I can do it every day 3 Hank as
you know I am a massive hypochondriac so
I don't like to touch my face because
that's how disease spreads but I find
that I actually touched my face less
when I'm wearing makeup because my face
is not like dry and itchy and etc 4 I
like the way I look it's pretty simple
actually I think when I was younger I
basically thought that women wore makeup
for men which speaks to a sick and very
deep part of the patriarchy in which men
imagined that women orient themselves
toward attracting men instead of having
like meaning and pleasure inside their
own lives that has nothing to do with
dudes when I wear makeup I genuinely
don't derive pleasure from thinking
about how I look to people watching me
on TV or whether it will make me more
attractive to other people I just like
the way I look it makes me happy now of
course lots of people don't like wearing
makeup which is totally cool but I do
that noted I'm probably not gonna be
wearing makeup on a daily basis partly
because I'm lazy partly because I am
tragically unamused
social conventions and partly because
I've been totally spoiled by having my
makeup done by amazing professionals
like Bridget but this whole experience
has made me a tremendous fan of makeup
and also of the YouTube makeup tutorials
so I put some links to my favorites in
the doobly-doo and Hank I also have to
say that I think you are super cool for
having more makeup in high school okay
now it's time for my big reveal
alright that was I look like my regular
self but better yeah perfect Hank
congratulations on VidCon I hope you're
getting some sleep I will see you on
Friday